dans le cinéma français il ya les grands
classiques qui au premier plan les plus
fameux film dont les dialogues ont été
écrits par michel audiard dont pour la
sortie d'un dvd regroupant ses
classiques justement une projection ait
lieu sur les grands boulevards à paris
comme au bon vieux temps ni a revu avec
plaisir les barbouzes et les tontons
flingueurs dont de nombreux français
connaissent les meilleurs dialogues
parker pascal deschamps fils épouse
d'eric les grandes heures seulement de
la lui rasait la fabrication et les
clients scène mémorable réplique
inoxydable
quarante ans après ils flottent toujours
et pourtant lorsque le public parisien
découvrit en avant de 63 la drôle de
famille d'audiard le succès fut mitigée
la critique condescendante la projection
organisée ce soir là n'avait pas valeur
de revente chenaux simplement l'occasion
de faire la nique aux destins avec les
copains ceux qui sont encore là
georges lautner le réalisateur jean
lefebvre dit jean volfoni samson raul
venantino venantini le porte-flingue du
mexicain et mireille darc qui n'était
pas dans les tons temps mais débuta avec
les barbouzes et tourne à 10 films avec
georges lautner du fait d une famille
c'est vrai que j'en avais envie de se
voir se parler
fille d'être ensemble et ne pas trop se
prendre au sérieux c'est bien sûr tout
ça notre notre problème c'est qu'on
voulait dès que quelqu'un se prenaient
au sérieux donc je peux vous dire que
moi ils m'ont beaucoup marqué les
terrils ordonnance est serré je vais lui
montrer qui c'est raoul pour quatre fois
le pari qu'on va le retrouver est
habillée par petits bouts façon puzzle
moi quand on m'en fait trop chaud et le
plus dynamique est différente il pour un
bel anniversaire ce fut un bel
anniversaire chocolats glacés ouvreuse
en robe vichy et réclame de l'époque
tout y était on aurait pu croire que le
temps s'était arrêté il ya des tontons
qu'on veut croire éternelle mais la
famille avait perdu trop de ses membres
pour ne pas leur dédier la soirée ces
moments et tous en même temps quelle
rigolade
bon si bien l'arrivée de l'aventuré
c'était une force approche de costauds
jamais de ses fruits en grand prix
après j'ai fait comme à vannes l'a créé
plus de boissons de bon la petite
histoire la gaumont voulait que jean
gabin joue le gugusse de montauban mais
c'est finalement lino ventura qui
accepta de tourner en dérision un
personnage de du rockeur gt on savait
qu'à beaucoup de nostalgie que gervois
un peu plus ça parce que par exemple la
scène dans la cuisine qui est très
importante
sur les 5 il reste 1 c'est moi
chiu
et larmes c'était vrai quand on a tourné
ils ont fait un mélange d'alcool qui m'a
pris à la gorge et qui m'a amené les
larmes aux yeux mais je ne savais pas
ils ont fait ça au moment de tourner et
pendant les répétitions c'était c'était
du jus de pomme
l'émotion de ses tontons la 16è plaisir
à voir et vous me croirez si vous voulez
nombreux sont ceux qui versèrent à leur
furie une larme mais ceux qui me
connaissent parole leur jette la
première pierre